joining me now to discuss prince philip
and his contribution
to the navy is former head of the royal
navy lord alan west
good morning to you um you describe him
as very much
a naval man this was his love after the
queen
absolutely he he was an exceptional
officer
and he loved to see and like all uh
semen officers
what he wanted to do was to command
ships and uh
of course because his career was
truncated he only
actually commanded one he commanded the
ship hms magpie
and he was uh he helped design the royal
yacht britannia which was so
so successful as a ship and so popular
with her majesty the queen
and in his cabin on board there if you
went in you found
on the desk was the model of the magpie
which was to remind him of that one
command
and there's no doubt i talked to him on
a number of occasions that
although he didn't make a big deal of it
you know he did he did
feel sad in a way that he had to give up
that uh that part of his career
um but he did it because he had a sense
of of duty
which is it was taught to you anyway at
dartmouth and in the navy
that's loyalty upwards and downwards and
uh he felt this sense of duty and of
course also let's not forget he was in
love with her majesty the queen and so
he gave up his naval career um and
willingly did that because uh
you know he felt these other things were
so important and uh it
shows it's a measure of the man but yes
clearly there was a little piece of him
that felt gosh wouldn't it be nice if i
stayed in the navy and he was on a he
was on a sort of golden track without a
doubt he would have
certainly gone into the very top
echelons of the navy if he stayed
and he would tell the most uh wonderful
stories of his his adventures and his
times in in the navy
can you share any of those with us
absolutely i mean he had exciting times
as as i suppose he was ever in ages but
he
he was a an officer during the second
world war
um you know he was at dartmouth uh when
he first met the queen he was only aged
17 or 18 i think
and she fell in love with him without a
doubt then um and they corresponded
through the war
he was a very brave officer he uh he was
in a way he was quite pleased when
greece came into the war because before
that he wasn't allowed to
fight on the rn ship so they came into
war in
1940 and uh he then served in the
mediterranean fleet uh he was got a
mention in dispatches
um operating searchlights on hms valiant
at the battle of cape matapan
um he did all sorts of other exciting
things he saved the ship he was a
first attendant off from attack by a
german aircraft with glider bombs by
launching a raft and having an alternate
target
and he marched on he was a very
successful first lieutenant
and took the ship out to the far east
but he had he had lovely stories um
uh for example in tokyo bay when the
ship was anchored there with the
american fleet as well
for the japanese surrender um he was
first attendant of the
of the ship he said he was called down
to the quarter net because two
emaciated and ragged figures had swung
out to the ship and climbed the ladder
onto the quarter deck
and he discovered they were two royal
marines who had been captured by the
japanese were in
prison at war camps in japan and he
talked about looking after them he's
quite emotional about it in a way
and he then said an extraordinary he
said i was
talking at her event in the in the north
of england in the
in the late 1950s and said how this had
happened
and from the back came hey that was us
and there were the two
royal marines who are in the audience at
the back of the hall and it he was quite
sort of emotional about that because
although his generation were taught not
to show emotion and they all called each
other by
surnames didn't mean they didn't feel it
and um
and i was very aware that he he felt
things strongly his
one of his most favorite songs was tom
bowling it's that it's that sad song
about her
sailor dying and going aloft it's a
lovely tune and that he really looked
pensive when that was played he really
felt it because of
so many friends he'd lost in the war um
so as i say an exceptional officer an
exceptional man
yes displayed a lot of skill in that
area was he
able to transfer those skills that he
learned in the navy
to his uh life within the royal family
oh he absolutely was and i think the
other thing of course he was
he was very very blunt he called a spade
a shovel and um
like all sorry in the navy actually i
was getting into trouble for it
um but you need to do that if you're if
you're commanding or
in a position of responsibility in a
ship in war as he was
for example on the convoys on the east
coast with attacks by
e-boats submarines there were mines
around
terrible weather risk of collision uh
you've got to be able to be
short quick and know what you're doing
and it might sound
abrupt but that's the way you have to
behave upwards and downwards and he
didn't care for flim flammary he uh
i i tried to get for him a baton i don't
know if you know the
field marshals have a bat on uh you
carry it it's a
beautiful piece of equipment made of
gold and with velvet
and uh there is one for the animals of
the fleet which we haven't really issued
for
well the last one that was issued was
issued to um the last duke of edinburgh
in the middle of the 19th century and
i thought for the bicentenary of
trafalgar would be nice
to give the one they'd started
constructing for mountbatten he was
killed in a
ira attack um to give that to him and uh
lots of people willing to pay for it
garage had almost made it
and i said to her majesty when i was
having an audience with him
you know i was thinking of doing this
and she said well i think we'd better
ask
philip so uh so he did that and back
came the message that he
he didn't want it he he said oh god no
he said this is
awful you know i've got to carry a sword
a wreath for the armistice thing i don't
want to carry a bloody bat on as well
and it was typical of him he didn't fuss
about these sorts of things you know
he was down to earth and uh i say a very
great man
yeah a straight talker lord alan west
thank you very much for sharing your
memories of the duke with us